[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo hier ist Mirko Kasimir herzlich
Willkommen zu Tatort Deutschland eurem
täglichen truecrime Podcast und da
unsere beiden krimi-königinnen Toni und
Natalie heute verhindert sind begrüße
ich an meiner Seite stephanette hallo
Stefan es ist mir ein Vergnügen Mirko
wir haben das ja schon mal gemacht und
es ist mir wirklich ein Fest genau und
unseren heutigen Fall um da mal
reinzukommen den könnte man auch mit ein
paar Magnetbändern erzählen die tief in
einem Keller des ZDF in Mainz gelagert
werden haben wir rausgefunden darauf ist
nämlich seit 1972 der Fernsehfilm mit
dem Titel der Soldaten Mord von Lebach
gespeichert die Produktion die hat
damals immerhin mehr als 1,2 Millionen
d-marke kostet aber sie wurde nie
gezeigt strittig waren nicht nur die
Persönlichkeitsrechte der mit vollem
Namen gezeigten Täter es ging auch darum
dass die Täter schwul waren und der Film
möglicherweise Hass auf Homosexuelle
wecken würde das ist selbst aus heutiger
Sicht eine spannende Debatte und wir
kommen noch darauf zurück aber wenn wir
uns diesem soldatenmord von Lebach heute
nähern dann sollten wir erstmal die
Opfer in den Vordergrund stellen
Unteroffizier Erwin Poe 21 Jahre alt
Obergefreiter Arno Bales 27
Gefreiter Dieter Horn 21 diese drei
sterben sofort der Gefreite Ewald Marx
und sein Kamerad Reinhard Schulz beide
20 werden schwer verletzt Max er liegt
diesen Verletzung schließlich und wenn
man auf die Fotos der Männer guckt dann
schaut man in junge aufgeweckte
Gesichter man sieht kurzhaarige Wache
Leute die noch das ganze Leben vor sich
haben sie befinden sich am 20 Januar
1969 gegen 2:50 Uhr im Munitionsdepot
Lebach im Saarland als der Überfall
beginnt ohne irgendwo auf Hindernisse zu
stoßen betreten zwei bewaffnete Männer
des Gebäude und attackieren die Soldaten
mit Schusswaffen und Messern
anschließend öffnen Sie 4 der 12
Munitionsbunker und entkommen mit 1.000
Schuss Gewehrmunition 50 Schuss
Pistolenmunition zwei Pistolen Walther
P1 und 3 schnellfeuergewehren Heckler
und Koch G3 die Zeitung Welt Titel
danach überall auf Munitionsdepot im
Saarland Großhandlung nach Mördern der
drei Bundeswehrsoldaten und dann wird
die Tat beschrieben unbekannte Täter
hatten in der Nacht zum Montag die drei
Soldaten der Wachmannschaft erschossen
und die beiden anderen durch Schüsse und
Stiche schwer verletzt die nachts
verübte Tat war am Montag um 7 Uhr
entdeckt worden als ein Kommando des
Bataillons das in der nur etwa einen
Kilometer entfernten Graf Heseler
Kaserne in Lebach stationiert ist zum
munitionsabholen vor dem Depot vor als
der Stabs Unteroffizier die Tür zum
Wachlokal öffnete fiel ihm ein schwer
verletzter Soldat der Gefreite Reinhard
Schulz mit den Worten in die Arme
Überfall
Überfall zwischen 3 und 4 Uhr morgens
Schulz 20 Jahre alt und in Dortmund
beheimatet war durch einen
lungensteckschuss einen armschuss und
Messerstiche verletzt Schulz konnte sich
dann noch zur Tür der Wachstube
schleppen das Land ist gleich aus zwei
verständlichen Gründen geschockt jemand
hat's grubbellos mehrere junge Soldaten
getötet und der Bundeswehrstandort war
so derartig schlecht gesichert dass man
sich ernsthaft Sorgen kann wie es um
andere Depots bestellt ist in der Welt
wird schon früh gemutmaßt dass ich die
Kette ausgekannt haben mussten im
Bericht heißt es nach Meinung
unterrichteter Bundeswehr Angehöriger
müssen die Täter genaue Ortskenntnis
gehabt haben in dem Drahtzaun der das
Depot umgibt wurden zwei Löcher gefunden
die fernsprechleitung war zerschnitten
wir sind muss man vielleicht noch mal
dazu sagen im Jahr 1969 also mitten im
Kalten Krieg das einfach jemand in eine
Kaserne spazieren Soldaten erschießen
und Munition klauen kann das
beunruhigend und das ist noch gelinde
ausgedrückt Geheimdienst jagt die Mörder
der drei Soldaten lautet am nächsten
Morgen die Schlagzeile von Bild darunter
die Gangster kamen in der Nacht sie
kletterten durch einen zaunloch
erschossen die Wachsoldaten und öffneten
die Munitionsbunker erst sechs Stunden
später konnte die Bundeswehr
alarmschlagen
Bundeskanzler und Bundestag schalteten
sich ein 10.000 Mark Belohnung die
Belohnung wurde später noch erhöht
erstmal gibt es keine heiße Spur und die
Spekulationen schießen ins Kraut war der
sowjetische Geheimdienst hier am Werk
linke Studenten der noch jungen außer
parlamentarischen Opposition hat die
Mafia sich Waffen besorgt angebliche
Bekennerschreiben der Mafia gehen bei
Bild und dem Spiegel ein unterzeichnet
von einem angeblichen Doktor Sardo die
Ermittlungen leitet Oberstaatsanwalt
Siegfried Bubak der später noch
Berühmtheit im Zusammenhang mit dem RAF
Terror erlangen wird traurige
Berühmtheit leider aber zurück ins Jahr
1969 es dauert noch bis zum 11 April bis
Bewegung in den Fall kommt und das hat
mit einer damals noch ziemlich jungen
Sendung zu tun
[Musik]
seit dem Oktober 1967 gibt es im ZDF
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst der Moderator
Eduard Zimmermann ruft darin zur
Aufklärung von Verbrechen auf nachdem
Soldaten Mord von Lebach wird die Tat
hier ausführlich und mit nachgestellten
Szenen erzählt unter anderem wird das
angebliche Erpresser Telegramm des Dr
Sardo gezeigt tausende Hinweise gehen
daraufhin ein und darunter zum Glück
auch der eine der entscheidende es ist
eine Zuschauerin aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
die die Kripo auf die richtige Spur
führt sie nennt sich Madame Buch Hela
und ist tatsächlich bundesweit bekannt
als die Wahrsagerin von Bonn hat mir
auch zu denken gegeben Mirko dass man
mit sowas früher noch berühmt werden
könnte zu ihren Kunden sollen Filmstars
und Politiker gehört haben und als
Kunden gaben sich offenbar auch die
späteren Mörder von Lebach aus als sie
zu madamebook Hela kam bürgerlich hieß
sie übrigens Margarete gussantier was
Madame Buch Hela zu erzählen hat ist
eine wirklich wilde Geschichte zwei
Männer sahen bei ihr gewesen ein
angeblicher dr Sardo und dessen Sekretär
sie erklärten sie kämen im Auftrag der
früheren persischen Kaiserin Soraya die
war elf Jahre zuvor geschieden worden
und lebte in Köln also meine Freunde
diese Nummer ist wirklich schräg dr Sado
und sein Assistent behaupten sie kämen
von der persischen Botschaft Soraya
wolle dass ihre Mutter die Zukunft
vorausgesagt wurde dazu müsste man aber
zu ihr fahren Madame bohela wiederum
lehnt ab denn ihr kommen die Männer und
Ihr Anliegen merkwürdig vor
normalerweise kommt die Kunden selbst
die Prominenten nämlich zu ihr zu der
Wahrsagerin nach Hause
Meter Sekretär versuchen sogar mehrfach
die Frau zum Mitkommen zu überreden die
wird immer misstrauischer und notiert
sich vorsichtshalber das Nummernschild
von sardos Auto dieses Kennzeichen und
die Beschreibung von Sardo und seinem
Sekretär nennt Madame bouchhela den
Leuten am Telefon von Aktenzeichen XY
und löst damit den Fall der Fall ist
ernst genug um das mal klarzustellen
aber das eine Wahrsagerin den
entscheidenden Hinweis gibt ohne dass
sie Wahrsagen muss das hat schon was für
mich ja finde ich auch aber wie sich
Zeit gibt es noch viel mehr schräge
Wendungen und Gedanken zwei Wochen nach
der Sendung werden zwei Männer
festgenommen sie heißen Wolfgang Dietz
und Hans-jürgen Fuchs sie sind keine
Mafiosi oder linke Terroristen oder
sowjetische Agenten sie sind der
angebliche dr Sardo und sein Assistent
und sie sind die Soldaten Mörder von
Lebach wenn hier keine politischen
Hintergründe im Spiel waren warum haben
dits und gestern Soldaten ermordet und
Munition geklaut warum wollten sie
unbedingt eine Wahrsagerin verschleppen
was hintergründe und Motiv angeht fängt
die Arbeit der Ermittler gerade erst an
kurz gesagt steckt ein schwules Trio
hinter der Tat und bei der Schilderung
dieser Lebensläufe schauen wir nicht nur
in die Archive von Bild und Welt wir
zitieren den Autoren Erwin in hat
panhäuser er ist Bibliothekar Journalist
beim Magazin quer und er befasst sich
mit schwuler Geschichte und er
beschreibt das Trio unter anderem mit
Hilfe eines Buches wiederum namens
kleinstadtmörder Spur 1081 des Reporters
Jürgen nevenaum jetzt haben wir die
Quellen sehr sorgfältig aufgeführt ich
finde dazu auch links in den Show notes
also los der Angestellte und
bundeswehrreservist Fuchs lebt im Feld
zwischen Landau und wird als
intelligenter Kopf des Trios beschrieben
er hätte gerne Psychologie studiert
wurde aber schließlich Bankkaufmann
Fuchs philosophiert viel über die
Gesellschaft und die schwierige Rolle
der schwulen er will für eine bessere
Zukunft kämpfen zur Not mit Gewalt im
Jahr 1959 lernt er Jürgen Dietz kennen
der als Justiz Sekretär beim Amtsgericht
arbeitet er ist übrigens auch Exsoldat
dies ist unglücklich mit seinem
Übergewicht und mit seiner
Homosexualität in Fuchs findet er eine
Art Mentor und Therapeut die beiden
Träumen zusammen von einer Gesellschaft
in der es schwule besser haben und von
einem Leben als reiche Leute in der
Südsee 1963 lernen Sie Gernot W Punkt
kennen auch der ist schwul auch er liebt
es nicht offen er arbeitet als
Zahntechniker so etwas ähnliches haben
wir erst 40 weil Sedlmaier thematisiert
nämlich das schwul seinen Deutschland
noch lange Zeit strafbar war Fuchs Dietz
und W Punkt teilen sich mit der Zeit
eine ziemlich schräge Gedankenwelt sie
wollen die Lage von Homosexuellen nicht
politisch ändern sondern fabulieren ein
freies Leben auf einem südamerikanischen
Landgut herbei oder wahlweise auch mal
eine Welt Umsiedlung und diese Ziele
wollen sie mit Erpressungen und
Überfällen finanzieren wie die Männer
immer krimineller wurden hat der Spiegel
1970 so aufgeschrieben Anfang 1965
reiften konkrete Pläne für erste
Raubüberfälle und im Juni Drang Fuchs in
Frauenkleidern getarnt in die
Stadtsparkasse Landau ein um statt
Bankkaufmann mal den Bankräuber zu
spielen
der Überfall missglückte doch noch im
gleichen Jahr Stahl Fuchs seinen Eltern
2000 Mark eine scheckfälschung bei der
Gernot W behilflich war brachte weitere
1.500 Mark ein Gernot W und Fuchs
reisten für mehrere Monate nach Spanien
in einem Museum in Madrid stahlen sie am
26 februar 1966 Schmuck und Antiquitäten
im Wert von etwa 40.000 Mark
justizekretär Dietz der daheim geblieben
war half später beim Absatz der heißen
Ware die Aktion werden immer
gefährlicher und auch größenwahnsinniger
ein paar Mal soll sich auch der eher
weichliche Diez bei Überfällen versuchen
versagt aber sie beginnen den Waffenraum
zu planen denn Fuchs kennt das
Waffendepot von eigenen Diensten am
Standort Lebach und sie kommen auf die
Crew die Idee mit madamebookera von ihr
wollen sie kompromittierendes über
Prominente erfahren und von diesen dann
Geld erpressen
wird
Diez wird von den anderen überredet
Waffen aus den asservaten seines
Gerichts zu entwenden Fuchs stiehlt bei
einem Manöver eine Pistole vom Typ P38
und bei gemeinsamen Schießübungen ist
auch Gernot wieder dabei beim tödlichen
Überfall am 20 Januar 1969 kommt er aber
nicht mit aber er hilft seinen Kumpanen
laut Anklage später die erbeuteten
Waffen zu verstecken in den Wochen bis
sie aufliegen verfolgen die Männer ihre
krankenpläne ernsthafterweise noch
weiter träumen weiter vom Auswandern und
verschicken weiter auch Erpresser
schreiben aber Madame Fehler und
Aktenzeichen XY beenden endlich diesen
mörderischen Quatsch am 29 Juni 1970
beginnt die Gerichtsverhandlung vor dem
Landgericht Saarbrücken weil die
Stimmung im Lande so aufgeheizt ist wird
die Verhandlung zu einem unwürdigen
Spektakel das Gericht tagt in der
Kongresshalle die hunderten erregten
Zuschauern Platz bietet einige von Ihnen
fordern lautstark die Todesstrafe und zu
allem Überfluss werden die Angeklagten
in einem Käfig präsentiert auch beim
Umgang mit der Homosexualität der
Angeklagten ist der Prozess ein Produkt
seiner Zeit selbst Richter tolle der das
Verfahren eigentlich besonnen leitet wie
Beobachter meinen lässt sich zu einem
zottigen Spruch hinreißen tolle sagt zum
Angeklagten w-punkt nämlich sie kennen
ja sonst wohl ihren Freund von innen und
außen die Menge jault schwulen Witze bei
einem Prozess wo es um vier Tote geht
ganz ehrlich wie stumpf kann man sein
absolut richtig absolut peinlich
das Urteil vom 7 August 1970 lautet
schließlich lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe
für die beiden Haupt Angeklagten und
sechs Jahre Freiheitsstrafe für den
dritt Beteiligten wegen Beihilfe zum
Mord und hier endet die Geschichte aber
nur fast Wolfgang Dietz kommt nach 23
Jahren Haft in den 1990ern frei aber
sein
Hans-jürgen Fuchs sitzt immer noch im
Knast dazu schreibt Bildreporter Steffen
Meyer im Jahr 2016 einen Artikel mit der
Überschrift Lebacher soldatenmode
Haupttäter will im Knast sterben und
weiter
zehn Quadratmeter Einzelzelle im Haus 4
der Saarbrücker JVA Fuchs ist nach
bildrecherchen der derzeit am längsten
inhaftierte Gefangene in Deutschland und
das seit 30 Jahren freiwillig denn Fuchs
hat seit ende 1985 das Recht einen
Prüfantrag auf Haft Entlassung zu
stellen hat das aber bisher nicht getan
warum nicht
ein ehemaliger Justizmitarbeiter der
Fuchs kennt er ist ein komischer Kauz
total verschoben er ist von seiner
Unschuld überzeugt und will das Urteil
nicht anerkennen auch der querjournalist
Erwin enthält panhäuser tritt in dieser
Zeit in Kontakt mit Fuchs also 2016 der
beteuert in einer Postkarte dir aus der
JVA schickt seine Unschuld außerdem sei
der mit Angeklagte w-punkt nie schwul
gewesen und vielleicht können wir uns am
Ende dieser Geschichte darauf einigen
dass die Unterdrückung von
Homosexualität zu dieser Zeit in diesem
Fall eine Rolle gespielt hat aber dass
diese Umstand selbstverständlich die Tat
selbst nicht entschuldigt finde ich gut
Mirko bin ich deiner Meinung und erst
recht gibt es keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen der sexuellen Orientierung und
der Frage ob man später zum Verbrecher
wird klar ist ja wohl vor allem dass die
Welt ohne Diskriminierung ein besserer
Ort wäre und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer heutigen Episode angelangt wir
danken euch dass er wieder
wir haben diese Folge erzählt mit Texten
von Bild Welt queer.de und Spiegel
Skript Stefan Netzeband Postproduktion
Wake Word Studios München wenn ihr
Anregungen Kritik oder Lob für uns habt
dann schreibt uns gern bei Instagram
oder an podcast@bild.de und vielleicht
habt ihr spannende Fälle die wir hier
mal besprechen sollen wir freuen uns von
euch zu hören bis zum nächsten mal euer
Mirko und euer Stefan